hello everyone and welcome again to
beginner breakdown my name is always
it's alex mullering and i'm going to be
your instructor for this evening tonight
our theme is on game analysis game
analysis 101 if you will how do you
analyze your chess games and why should
you
so i've picked a few games from students
of mine that i've personally taught as
well as games that i've been involved in
that i think are going to be instructive
for this purpose and we're going to look
at both sides and see what could each
side have done to improve and then ask
ourselves why is analyzing games
valuable and how should we go about it
so in this first game
it's two anonymous players i'm not going
to be naming any of the names of the
students
but
we're going to be going through their
games so in this set
hello
uh in
this game
it's a fairly short game i believe but
it's hopefully going to be valuable for
us and the players were about 500 and
600
so in this game we started with e4
e5
and bishop to c4
already some people might not be as used
to this most people are going to be more
accustomed to the natural knight to f3
so
we might have to keep an eye on this
bishop move it actually will cause maybe
a few issues for someone who's not
prepared
well uh the student here responds with a
very natural move knight to f6 seeing
okay well i'm gonna keep doing what i'm
doing you haven't attacked my pawn so i
have no need to defend it
so i'm just going to attack here on uh
e4
and white responds
knights to f3
so already might be a bit of an unusual
move right
white is electing not to defend their e4
pawn
if you had black in this position what
might you choose to do
would you try and uh defend your pawn
here
with a move would you try and attack or
something else how about you play
any ideas move for black what would you
do in this position
okay take the pawn
seems like a logical choice right uh if
our opponent's choosing to give us a
pawn
anyone else knight c6 in the chat brent
knight c6 just maybe defending and
fortifying our center
yeah i think these are both good moves
uh the move played in the game
was d6
and
i don't think it's a bad move but i
think it is a little conservative maybe
a little slow trying to you know hold
the center
black does have a nice pawn chain
working towards the center but there is
a slight issue with this move
while we allow our light squared bishop
to get involved in the game we do limit
our dark squared bishop considerably
at this point its options are either
it's going to go to e7 or possibly
it might go to g6 or sorry g7 someday if
we ever play g6
but we've taken away the options of
bringing it to c5 or b4 so
anytime you make a move like this you
have to consider you know you're
limiting your options in this way
now knight to c6
also looks like a very natural move
controlling the center
and defending our pawn
and i'm suspecting uh the reason
our player with the black pieces didn't
go into this line is because now we've
actually transposed if white chooses to
do so to the intimidating fried liver
attack
where the knight and bishop are both
hitting this pawn normally we would see
this position arise
in a standard knight to f3 game with
knight to c6
bishop to c4 and if now black chooses to
play knight to f6
then knight to g5 and this is perfectly
playable a lot of master games have
happened in this way
but both sides really have to know what
they're doing
and i'd say even more so the side with
black because if you don't it's very
easy to just get blown off the board
this f7 square is a huge target early in
the game
because it's only defended by the king
and so black's going to need to be very
precise and so i suspect uh our player
here with the black pieces decided not
to play knight c6 to avoid this
very variation
here
uh which is maybe one uh idea where why
the opponent plays bishop to c4 move two
maybe kind of tricking our opponent into
a false sense of security thinking okay
well i'm not defending the pawn i'm
giving you the chance to play this move
and attack but now gamuting this pawn
off
is going to you know
allow this unfortunate transition here
the move knight takes e4 also
suggested quite a lot
and if we look at this um there's no
more ideas of knight to g5 because our
knight and queen both cover that square
so that's not a threat but there is the
threat of knight takes e5
continuing this attack
and uh how would you continue here
especially if you wanted to play knight
takes e5 you're sorry knight takes e4
what should black do here to survive
so it's black's turn to move we'll go
back and move or two
um so after knight to f3 our
player here with black played d6
but
had you decided to take this pawn
then knight takes e5 is a very strong
looking natural move right attacking f7
with the bishop and the knight
we have a few suggestions in the chat
but i'll give our in-person audience
just another few seconds here
i take my knight to
d3
d6 here you mean
yeah absolutely yeah no you're the if
you had white it would be v3
yeah so knight d3 with the idea that our
knight is defending this pawn i think
that's uh that makes sense
my one caution with this move would be
that again we're kind of blocking our
pieces in
so it's going to be harder for right one
this bishop but even more so this bishop
because this pawn can't do anything
um so that is always a bit of something
you have to be careful of you don't want
to block these pawns into early it's
going to make our development a lot
slower
a few people in the chat are suggesting
queen to f6
queen f6 is an interesting move
because the idea is wait we're not
actually stopping our opponent from
taking this pawn
if they take with the knight that's real
bad
what should black do here
[ __ ] has a really strong response if
they decide to take with the knight and
attack the rook
queen to f2
checkmate right we got to be careful of
our you know uh f square
but white's got to do the same
so knight takes is no good however
bishop can take and this is check
our king's gonna have to move somewhere
but even still in this position maybe
it's not the worst it's gonna be
complicated um because now our queen is
gonna be attacking both uh the bishop
and the knight
and also threatening checkmate
so our opponent's gonna have to be real
careful how are you going to keep all of
these pieces alive and how are you not
going to lose the game there's a lot
that both sides have to worry about here
right
so this could be a very if you're a more
aggressive
player with who likes lots of tactics
this could be something for you
um
now obviously
white is not obliged to take here they
could maybe play a retreating move like
knight back to f3 but if your opponent
is playing this kind of retreating move
then maybe we're doing okay in the
opening anyway
uh queen of six the other move that's
been suggested in the chat that i
actually probably would play would be d5
a very strong move controlling the
center attacking our opponent's bishop
and cutting it off importantly from this
square
so there's no more ideas of one of these
pieces taking over here
um
and this could get a little dangerous
for our opponent right uh to me a very
natural move looks like bishop back to
b3 you know keeping pressure on this
diagonal but there's actually a very
serious problem with this move and i
want to see if anybody can find it how
can black play here and actually get a
really nice advantage
uh queenie 7 suggested 27 uh really
interesting move i'm guessing your idea
is you're attacking the knight and if
the knight moves we have a beautiful
discovered check so something like this
let's say the knight just goes back to
f3 we can actually now move our knight
and cult check on the king maybe
something like knight to c3
and our queen attacks the king
and in this position probably the
queen's gonna
i guess the king has to move but
regardless of what happens we can take
the queen
if the queen blocks then we will take it
with checkmate
so that's yeah unfortunate
um
but i think uh white can do a little
better here after queen to e7 instead of
moving the knight perhaps they'll just
fortify it with maybe d4
um there's also maybe the possibility
that they counter attack maybe something
like d3 and attack our knight
so
it's going to be unclear this is an
interesting idea but there's something a
little stronger
knight takes f2 also suggested i think
this might be a little ambitious
it's possible there might be some
tactical tricks here with maybe bishop
c5 or queen to f6 or h4
um but it might be a little ambitious
i think the move that's even a little
stronger
is queen to g5
and we are forking our opponents knight
and their pawn here on g2
once you've saved the knight we're going
to take this pawn threaten the rook and
our opponent their king will be fairly
vulnerable
but yeah knight f2 does look kind of
interesting
uh but i want to back up
because we're getting a little bit into
the weeds
the goal of analysis right the reason
we're looking at all of this is to
consider really we're asking the
question okay we end up in this
situation
with the black pieces that maybe we
don't like
um we found that oh boy after knight to
f3 if i take this pawn maybe i'm doing
okay but i'm gonna have to know
maybe some theory i'm gonna have to do
some study of this
if i play knight to c6 again same thing
maybe they do a fried liver
so what i'm trying to present is if you
get into this situation we have two
options
one
when we're analyzing our game we can go
back and say okay i didn't like what
happened in the opening i'm going to
take a look and figure out what could i
have done differently
and if there's nothing like all of these
options i think the d5 at some point
knight takes all of these options are
worth considering
but what you want to evaluate for
yourself is okay is this something that
i want to spend time looking into or do
i need to go back even farther
and say in this position if you play
bishop to c4 all of this mess might have
started because i played knight to f6
so maybe
in this position you just play
conservatively and keep going with
knight to c6 if that's your plan or d6
and you kind of don't worry about this
because without knight to f6 there's
never going to be this threat
of knight coming to g5 our queen is
going to hit it when our knight is here
on f6 the queen actually gets in the way
so again just options to consider but
when you're analyzing your games these
are what should be going through your
mind
looking at different ways you can fight
back or trying to prove how you played
at every move and sometimes that means
realizing okay maybe i just end up in a
position i don't want to be in i should
have done something a move earlier
but let's continue with what actually
happened in the game so d6 and knight to
g5
and here
uh there is a lot of pressure on f7 and
at this point you know it's one thing to
analyze the game and try and think okay
yeah i could have improved before
but we're also going to make mistakes
and get into situations that are a
little hairy so we should still figure
out the best moves to play from here
what should black do what would you play
is there anything to get us out of the
situation or
are we already in a bind
bishop to e6
bishop to e6 uh makes sense right we're
cutting off the scope of this attack
from the bishop
uh
so we're at least protecting f7 this is
actually what was played in the game
so
not a bad move maybe the second best
move
i think there's a move that i like a
little more but bishop e6 is not bad
uh yeah holy pals in the chat or ollie
powell's not sure how you say that name
d5
again cutting off the scope of the
bishop this way the reason i like d5
slightly more than bishop to e6
is because after bishop to e6
we notice that the knight and bishop are
both attacking this piece and it is only
defended once
so white is going to win a pawn which
they end up doing knight takes pawn
takes bishop takes
and black is now in a bind these light
squares are dominated by our opponent's
bishop
they have infiltrated our territory and
we have to play the next few moves very
carefully not to you know allow that to
mess us up right we're not gonna be able
to castle as long as that piece is there
and we're down a pawn
but if we had played d5 here uh it's
still going to be tough right
white can play a lot of tricky moves but
with best play we can survive we're
cutting off this piece
and it's defended adequately
both sides are going to have to be
careful here
but let's continue with what happens in
the game bishop e6 knight takes f takes
and bishop takes
and here again
in a position
where
you know we're down upon and maybe
you know have some issues with these
light squares
we still need to make a game plan what
should we do in this type of position
maybe suggest even the next move or just
an idea for how you want to continue and
try and you know rebuild our position
what should we be shooting for with the
black pieces here
could you do night to
uh do you want the knight that's on the
back row or the one that's yeah
okay do you want it to come up here or
the second option or over here
that kind of these we'll say this is
one this is two and this is three you
got green red and blue
uh so the green one
uh yeah so i think you could make an
argument to put the knight on either of
these squares
um
knight to c6 is a little more maybe
involved in the center but what's your
idea with knight to d7
why do you want to put the knight here
well then bishop can't i mean i mean
they can't take but if they do then it's
defended by the queen
uh yeah so
yeah so this piece is definitely
defended um and we wouldn't mind if they
decide to trade i guess to take away
this attacking piece something else
you're doing that uh you may have
realized it is you're cutting off the
bishop's scope
on our c-square which means if we want
if we get this queen out of the way we
can actually queenside castle which is
going to be important right we need to
get our king safe
especially when again our opponent is
controlling these squares so maybe doing
something like developing this piece and
allowing ourselves to castle is going to
be important
anyone have
other ideas or is anyone like that plan
what else might we consider
but knight takes the pawn on e4
okay knight takes pawn on e4 it's funny
that's also what was played in the game
yeah i guess i might have stolen this
from you
um yeah knight takes e4 we'll consider
that in a moment because it was played
in the game uh but olly pals in the chat
to suggest that again another move i
actually would probably play this move
uh queen to e7 i would do this first
because again i think the knight to d7
or even knight to c6 plan there's
another plan um if you want to that's i
think if you want to castle queen side
you're probably going with this plan if
you want to castle king side again it
will probably be risky but we're
probably going to try and play g6
and bishop to g7 get a little you know
safe four to five area over here but
regardless i want to play queen e7 first
because i want to ask this bishop a
question
one i'm saying you don't belong here go
away because you cannot stay you're
attacking too many of my squares
and they got to pick if they want to
retreat
this way or this way
and that can inform how we continue our
plan
if the bishop decides to go along this
diagonal and they really want to keep
putting pressure on our queen side maybe
now we switch gears maybe we play g6
bishop g7 kingside castle and fight on
and the fact that we're down this uh f
pawn
if we just play let's say a few kind of
normal looking moves
the fact that we're down this f pawn you
know it's never great to be down a pawn
but it's actually kind of nice in this
case because it gives us a semi-open
file for our rook
our work once our knight moves our rook
is going to be you know directly
targeting our opponent's king
so maybe we can try and double up our
rooks
and put some pressure at least we have
something to fight for so that could be
a plan
if our opponent decides what i think
looks a little more natural and uh goes
back to maybe c4 or b3
and stays on this diagonal now i think
castling queenside is a very realistic
plan we can play knight to d7 or c6
and then castle inside and again either
way we have something we're fighting for
we've gotten our king safe
uh so that's the move i would play first
forcing our opponent to make a decision
and i'm okay with blocking off the
bishop because i don't really think it's
gonna do much on e7 anyway
i would rather eventually get it on this
diagonal where at least might you know
challenge our opponent um here on e7
it's probably just going to be a tall
pawn
and i want my bishop to do a little more
than that
but in the game we have knight takes e4
this is actually um
according to the engines
fine
it's
at least no worse than any other option
black has but it is a little ambitious
uh i would be a little afraid to play
this move because while i do want to get
this material back
now
uh white can launch some fairly
devastating attacks that we're going to
have to really carefully defend
let's say you're white in this position
what moves might you consider to try and
you know regain some advantage
or maybe press your advantage
if you don't know the square you can
describe it like all the way to the edge
one up
what do you what are you looking at um
yeah uh right here
you're good so this is queen to g4
okay what's your idea with queen g4
um
well for sure
well oh no and also i was thinking about
the rope
uh yeah so you're definitely putting
some pressure on our king side and we're
gonna have to be a little careful here
you're also attacking our knight and you
are defending your bishop and you know
putting more pressure on d7 so i think
for all those reasons this looks like a
natural move
um
i think maybe the one issue is we're
creating several problems to me the main
problems are we're getting near our
opponent's king and we're attacking this
knight
but i think just playing knight to f6
might solve some of those i'm bringing
my knight back i'm attacking your queen
now
and white's not worse here but
i think there's something a little
better
in the chat we have a few suggestions a
few people are thinking queen to f3 as a
move some someone suggested queen h5
check
and i think both of these moves serve a
similar purpose uh queen to f3 does a
similar thing to queen to g4 where we're
attacking this knight
um
but instead of defending the bishop
queen to f3 is actually making a really
big threat what's the other threat
that's
yeah checkmate right checkmate here on
f7 so we're attacking the knight and
attacking f7 again i don't like queen f3
as much i think it's fine but we're
allowing our opponent to just bring this
knight back and kind of consolidate
defend some of these weaker squares
for that reason i think queen h5 very
strong move it might not be the top
engine move but i like it a lot
i also don't mind d3 someone suggested
d3 attacking the knight and just getting
our bishop out in the game you know
healthy development is always going to
be good
one of the benefits of this move is
after something like knight back to f6
you can play bishop to g5 and you know
keep amping up the pressure
pinning the knight
so not a bad way to continue either but
queen h5 and this is actually the
continuation that happens
in our game
uh yeah brent 202 you're on to something
we'll come back to that idea uh shortly
um
yeah so queen h5 check
and obviously checkmate is threatened so
we probably don't want to move the king
this would just be a disaster i think
that's just straight up checkmate in one
so instead g6 is played
and here uh queen to f3
is played now
kind of provoking g6 first
and it is a very deadly threat so as we
said we are continuing this attack
i think one of the reasons this is nice
is it takes a little bit of uh like now
if knight to f6
then
it's defended by the queen but it's no
longer defended by this pawn and maybe
we can try and take advantage of this
knight being a little weaker and tied to
this square
but there are some serious problems here
so if you're black in this position how
do we continue
what should we do is knight to f6 the
only move
because we do need to stop checkmate
uh yeah queen e7
uh stopping checkmate
what if i just take your knights
yes so we trade pieces so not bad but
this actually opens up the second
problem that brent was uh asking about
in the chat
what's the second problem we have here
again if you're not sure the square you
can kind of describe it it's kind of
hard to see
all the way to the
right
over here yes
uh queenie for check not bad but i don't
want to check that's not doing anything
else because i might just be able to
block this
[Music]
white has a slightly better move here
oh
to
be
yeah uh
and yeah brent and klepp in the chat
yeah you both saw this as well queen
takes b7
and now how do we save our rook
this is going to be trouble
and this is actually a bit of the
problem and the point of queen f3 anyway
is
the knight is attacked checkmate is
threatened
and they're looking over here at this
pawn on b7
so already we're in a lot of trouble um
if knight to f6 then queen takes b7 and
this in this case we're not losing the
rook um because it's defended you know
once we move this knight
but
our position is kind of falling apart
right we still haven't dealt with this
bishop
and all of our our pawns are starting to
become isolated
this is just getting harder and harder
to defend
another possible move here
is uh
uh questor 52
i suggested knight to g5
actually a kind of nice move we are
again going to lose this pawn there's no
way to stop it
um
but we are hitting the queen and the
bishop
and we're defending our checkmate square
so this is a very active move uh that's
at least you know gonna give us some
fighting chances
in the game the move here played was d5
um realizing the threat of the rook and
the knight but unfortunately missing the
bigger picture
and allowing queen to f7 checkmate
so let's quickly go back
if we look at the start of this game
what have we learned you know in
retrospect looking at this game a second
time through that we may not have known
the first time around
we look at e4 e5
to me these moves are about the same but
bishop c4 i'm starting to see a little
differently
i'm starting to think if i'm someone
who's going to play e5 in these moves
now i need to be aware that even though
i don't have to defend this pawn
maybe i just want to do that anyway
because if i play knight f6 and attack
this pawn it looks like such a natural
move
i can run into some situations that
maybe i'm not super familiar with
and if you want to take some time and
study these lines uh black can get a
really nice position white is gambiting
a pawn
um and if you can hold on to that you
can you know really do well but you're
gonna have to know your stuff because
there's a lot of tricks and a lot of
traps here
so you can kind of get the choice
already through analyzing and the next
time you're in a game and someone plays
the same kind of opening against you
we're going to have a sense of what to
do
but more than just openings
game analysis really helps i think with
every stage of the game
d6 we can already start to think about
what our moves are doing what they're
limiting us from doing
and we can think of options right in
this case uh bishop e6 seems like the
only
saving grace
but it allows you know this kind of nice
trade for our opponent
so maybe now seeing in these positions
okay well if i'm in a bind like this
maybe i have to play d5 this move is
actually a really nice resource in a lot
of lines where your opponent is
targeting this square especially when
they have a bishop uh on c4 or queen on
b3
anything like this d5 is a really good
resource
just because it cuts off this attack and
sometimes you don't even take the pawn
back sometimes there's uh i think in
this line the best move is h6
forcing the knight away and then you
play e4 attacking it again and you
haven't even taken this pawn back but
we're we're keeping this bishop off the
diagonal and fighting for control of the
center
so just keeping a sense of what our
options are and what moves can lead us
into some rough territory bishop e6
knight takes knight takes and bishop e6
and again we can kind of think
okay what we've already seen here
well
even if i don't end up in a game in this
position right if i don't play this
opening
i might have a game where i've kind of
messed up a little bit i've traded upon
i have some weaknesses against my king
and my opponent is infiltrating my space
so what do i want to do well i would say
let's challenge this piece we're gonna
play a forcing move attack our
opponent's piece force it to move away
um and then we can once they've made a
decision we can make our plan according
to that
maybe castle queenside or maybe castle
kingside
and our moves are going to you know kind
of come naturally from how our opponents
playing
but we can already start to have these
plans on our head before we play them
and we get that i think uh in some way
from analyzing this game
so
that's the first game i wanted to look
at
why don't we jump in
to another one here
there we go
okay
uh we actually have a similar uh i think
ending to this game
but let's see how it starts this one
actually starts with the queen's uh
queen's pawn so if you are a d4 player
or a d5 player you can celebrate because
your opening is getting looked at a
little bit
in this game knight to f3 is played
bishop to f5
e3 and e6 and i really like what black
is doing here
choosing to get the bishop out and
developed before playing e6 you know if
we had done this order a little
differently
e6 first
uh this is maybe a more french style
structure unfortunately now this bishop
is going to be a little it's unclear
what we want to do with it right we're
limiting our options so playing bishop
f5 first controlling some space
and then e6 i think a very solid game
plan
and here white decided to play
bishop to d3 immediately challenging
uh this piece preparing to castle
and i think this is a fine move
in this position
white decided or sorry black decided to
trade i don't think it's the only move
perhaps you can retreat back or maybe
pin this knight but trading is fine here
the most important thing is black wanted
to make this structure
but they didn't want this bishop to be
impeded so trading in a way no issue
there
but here i think is the first uh mistake
of the game
bishop to d6 is played and it looks like
a very natural move
um you know getting another piece
developed
just fighting a little more for control
of the center maybe especially this e5
square maybe at some point we're gonna
break here
but it does leave us a little vulnerable
what can white play here to gain an
advantage
see if you can find the best move
yep brent 202 you've got the right idea
again
queen to b5 check forking our king and
our b7 pawn
very similar to our last game again kind
of thematically interesting there
and the issue is whatever we play
we are losing this pawn
so say queen to d7 or knight to d7 um
this pawn is falling and it's not the
end of the world we're not losing this
rook but
it is going to be a little harder
for us
so having that in mind
what might have been a better way for
black to play
instead of playing a bishop to d6 now
that we know that this threat is on the
horizon
what can we do to
prevent it
how would you play with the black pieces
on the c7
uh c6 here sorry c6 yeah i think this is
a fine move um
you're really you know have a really
nice pawn structure here on the light
squares
and that's going to be i think aided by
this dark squared bishop they are really
going to complement each other
maybe one slight issue i have is this
knight is perhaps not as good it's going
to go to d7 or a6 instead of c6 where it
would like to but again that's okay
i think the bigger critique is i want to
play knight to d7 but then i kind of
want to play c5
right this bishop and knight are both
going to be defending c5
and so if that's what i want to do
why not do it right away
i kind of like this move here
c6 again not a bad move but i would
rather play c5 and fight for control
uh kinda yeah right it's very similar um
some sicilians will do a similar thing
um but we're gonna you know fight for
the center in some lines we might even
push forward but usually we're just
going to trade
and
queen to b5 is not a threat anymore
because how can we respond now
wait a c7
uh well let's check oh i'm sorry yeah
you're right
yeah queen to d7 we're cutting off the
check but now with our c pawn out of the
way we're defending both threats
so i kind of like c5 a little more c6
not a bad move
like if you play this in your game
that's fine
uh it's a little more you know
positional structural and i want to be a
little more aggressive maybe but yeah
not a bad move in the slightest you
could also just play knight to c6 if you
wanted you know developing a piece
maybe a little less ideal because again
probably we want to eventually use our c
pawn to break in the center
and with this knight on c6 it's going to
be a little hard to do that
but with that on c6 maybe there's no
ideas of again
fighting for control of e5
so to each their own there
but in our game bishop d6 and uh luckily
in this case for black the opponent did
not recognize the idea
and played a knight to d7
knight to f6 again developing still
leaving this threat on the table but
again white hasn't seen it
so e4
now a big threat
obviously e5 is
a pretty big issue forking our rook and
our bishop so we have to deal with this
somehow and probably the simplest is to
take
maybe there's other moves here um
maybe like bishop f4 or something but to
me it seems like taking is just the very
natural
move
so yeah so taking
knight takes
and
we have some exchanging here in the
center
c6
castling looks nice but again we have
this issue on b7 so c6
uh cutting off our opponent's control
and still you know even without a pawn
on d5 maintaining nice defense of these
light squares
so the queen reroutes to g5 maybe a bit
aggressive perhaps castling or
developing our bishop would have been a
little stronger but queen to g4 or sorry
queen to g4 and now again there's a
threat
looks like our
pawn is hit what should we do
black to move and kind of make a plan to
deal with this
what might you play if you had black in
this position
uh castle well you're braver than most
um this looks a little scary
this is probably a move i would play too
so uh i don't blame you but there could
be some issues right what if um
i think a very thematic idea might be
something like bishop to h6
threatening mate your pawn is pinned so
you can't take
um how would you play here
move your
uh
your queen in front of the elder queen
uh here yeah
uh we could although that's a bit scary
because it's attacked a lot
we probably don't want to lose our queen
so i think a little better would be um
oops
to not go quite that far but go to f6
instead
defending our pawn
um brent actually was suggesting we do
this first he wanted to play queen f6
first and then castle
um i think that's a possibility although
maybe then bishop to g5 comes out with
tempo
so i still like castling first a little
more
but yeah after queen to f6 everything is
holding and it may look a little scary
but
i'm not really concerned for black's
position here
really worst case we can move this rook
out of the way
and bring our bishop back to defend but
i don't even think that's going to be
necessary right our immediate threat is
taking this bishop
um
and if you play bishop to g5 now for
instance then probably just queen to g6
pinning it to your queen
and again black is doing quite all right
here
um
instead unfortunately uh i think these
threats just looked a little too scary
so our opponent or sorry our player here
with the black pieces played the move g6
which does stop this threat
i see this move a lot more or this type
of move a lot
in some french or sicilian games where
the queen comes to b6
and it's putting pressure on the center
and also hitting this pawn on b2 and
sometimes opponents will play a move
like b3 to avoid that
generally it's not ideal in this case
it's again it's a bit weakening of these
dark squares
and with our bishop kind of committed
over here to d6 it's maybe not ideal now
again this is not the worst move um
black can always castle
and
get their bishop rerouted to g7 but i
think it's a little it's going to take a
little more effort
in this position
knight to g5 was played
again white is being a little over
ambitious i think right playing some
aggressive moves queen coming to g4
uh now the knights coming out and making
some threats i suppose but
all of them are sacrificial and none of
them are set up yet
i still think probably developing
and preparing to castle or just castling
right away would be a little better
but knight to g5 not
a terrible move
and white or sorry black now decides to
castle
queen to h4
and here's where our uh
player the black pieces goes a little
bit wrong
unsure how to respond to this threat uh
they're i think rated about six seven
hundred uh made decided to try and make
an escape square
seeing that there's a checkmate threat
so i'm going to make an escape square
move my rook and i'm gonna run my king
and get away unfortunately this doesn't
quite work what's the problem here how
did white respond in the game
okay and
the point of black is to make this
escape to f8 so how would you continue
then you take the quad in front of the
key
yeah so black solves mating one and
walks right into maiden two
uh unfortunately
so
this plan uh was not the best
what's a better
move we can play in this type of
position
how can we not lose this game what would
you have done instead
uh yeah pawn h5 and uh questor in the
chat also suggested that yeah i think
this is our best move
and
it might still be a little scary to
defend um probably the scariest move
here would be
g4 threatening to take and obviously if
we take
this checkmate idea still exists
so this is going to be a bit tough to
deal with but i think with best play
black can survive
in this position how might you try and
stay alive
this one's a bit tougher
bishop to
uh e7 yeah
yeah and your idea is you're putting
more pressure on this knight um yeah i
don't think that's a bad move bishop e7
i think there is a slight issue though
because it's defended by uh their bishop
so if they just decide to take
um
takes takes
and
it's maybe not the most pleasant
experience for us
i don't think we're getting checkmated
immediately but we are going to have to
really be careful of it
uh yeah questor again nice idea this
one's a little harder to spot but the
move i would play
i don't actually know if i would even
find this move it's a little tough but
it's f6 um
making a bigger threat there's no time
for white to take our pawn because we're
attacking their knight now yes this
castle structure doesn't look great
um admittedly but
it's better than uh than this one
so you got to kind of just do what you
have to do um
and with f6 uh
it looks maybe at first the knight to e6
forking our rook and queen
is
something we've overlooked but actually
this is okay
because we can move one of these pieces
and pin the knight to the king
so it's going to be tough but black can
kind of squeeze by
just barely
um
if you really want to get ambitious i i
was actually working with my student on
this game
they had the black pieces and i was
saying okay the escape if you if you
don't see the move h5 um and you see
that this is not going to work but you
want you want to try something else
another move that's going to last a
little longer is king to g7
with the idea that at least now this way
we have this escape square this is going
to be unpleasant as well
i don't know exactly what the best move
here is but i'm sure it's something
probably just queen to h4
the knights threatening to come in and
the bishop can come in and yeah white
has a lot of threats but
it's not made
so we've at least beaten checkmate in
two
so always keep you know your creative
mind thinking but yeah if you see this
nice idea
uh h5
it is going to help save the game
so again let's jump back a little bit
and consider this game
from the top
these opening moves i think made sense
there was no major issue
but already on move five bishop to d6
uh we said was a mistake because if you
recall
black is or sorry white is threatening
this fork of our pawn on b7 and our king
so maybe if you're a kind of person who
goes for these structures um
this is
very uh very french-esque structure or
karo khan for e4 players will sometimes
get the bishop out to f5
but also here in any like queen's
queen's gambit sometimes it'll happen
in like a slav
but regardless if this is a type of
structure you might play this is a
pretty common idea right to white for
white to try and take control
and trading is fine but you have to
recognize that now this queen has some
threats
continuing with the game um
again i don't think there were any other
major issues to look at until this move
our opponent is being a little
aggressive
and i think it's important to recognize
okay what are their threats
and what are maybe were our
exaggerations of their threats in the
game g6 is played because it looked like
there was too much pressure uh brent
actually talks about g6 instead of
knight g5 he liked the move bishop h6
um so yeah i wanted to get back to that
in the chat you said that a little bit
ago idea is we're preventing castling i
think this is probably better than
knight g5 frankly
um
it's again black's maybe not lost but it
does immediately question why we're
opening up these dark squares
but i think we can all learn from this
type of position and say okay
there are some threats maybe against my
king
is it safe to castle is it not um and in
this case it's actually safe to castle
if we can recognize what resources we
have available
our queen coming to f6 is really huge
um
and possibly our bishop eventually
dropping back to f8
and choosing not to castle is going to
cause more problems than it's worth
lastly here when we're in situations
where checkmate is being threatened you
want to consider all your options
um and see what we can get away with
maybe another move to think about in
these types of situations would be like
f6 or f5 now in this specific case it
doesn't work because the knight's still
controlling that square
but moving upon to create an escape
could be an avenue to consider it
sometimes
but yeah keeping our options open and
being aware of what our opponent can do
okay we have about 10 minutes left i
want to look at one game uh
that i played here against one of my
students another short game but i do
think it's uh fairly instructive
i don't think it's this one
here we go
so we're not going to do as hyper
analysis of this game because we don't
have quite as much time but i want to
kind of talk it through
in this game i have the white pieces and
my opponent plays e6 the french defense
um signaling probably wants to play d5
you know we're supporting this square
and you want to challenge white's uh e
for pawn
so i played d4 kind of the main move d5
and knight to d2
this is uh the taurus variation of the
french if you're not familiar there's
some really good youtube videos on it
that i'd encourage you to check out or
just read up on but it's one of the main
sidelines against
the french defense
pawn takes pawn
knight takes back
and bishop to e7
this is a little unusual but it's not a
bad move by any means it's you know
natural developments maybe a bit
conservative
but also supporting maybe a knight
coming to f6
and preparing to castle king side
bishop to d3
and b6
uh this move is a bit too slow
normally we probably would want to keep
you know following the plan that we had
said of knight to f6 developing pieces
uh b6 a little bit too slow
though the idea makes sense you want to
get this light squared bishop on the
long diagonal seeing as e6 has cut it
off
but again there is a bit of a problem
um
i do want to give kudos to my opponent
for not making the mistake of playing
queen takes d4
right after bishop d3 i've cut off the
communication for my queen so it looks
like this might be a free pawn what is
the issue for black here why should you
not take this pawn
yeah bishop to b5 is a bit of a problem
uh to check on our king the queen is
discovered attacking our black's queen
uh and yeah there's no way to save your
queen
you either stop the check with some move
and i take your queen or you block with
the queen and i take it sadly with the
bishop so
uh yeah so good on my opponent for not
taking this pawn instead goes for
development and here i play the move
queen to g4 continuing i guess the theme
of this lesson i didn't realize is these
uh how do we deal with protecting these
uh these pawns right here
because in this case i am launching an
attack and i'm asking a question about
why bishop to e7 was played again i said
this is a little unusual
and it probably would have been fine if
my opponent had stuck with the plan
right you know developing pieces
kingside castling and not giving me
enough time
to launch and be hyper aggressive here
but because of this move bishop to e7
and choosing to play b6 instead of
normal developing ideas
it does allow me to create a weakness
here so if you have
the black pieces how might you respond
in this situation
now that a little problem has been
created what can we do about it
develop the knight and attack the queen
uh yeah i there's two ways we can do
that you want to go to h6 or f6
um
i think you want to do it on
f6
yeah probably f6 is going to be more in
the center i think there is maybe a
slight issue
with this
is that the pawn is still undefended
so you are you know attacking the queen
and maybe that's worth it
or maybe i guess you could even play
here with the knight on f6 um
and we're fighting back but
we're now gonna have to really get into
high gear to get our king safe um
probably trying to aggressively
queenside castle
because otherwise we are going to be
stuck here in the open but again maybe
not the worst scenario a little bit
risky but maybe not the worst
um
in the chat someone suggesting bishop f6
i think this move is a little stronger
it gives up the bishop pair yes but it
does defend g7
and if the knight takes
then the queen can take and keep that
pawn safe
or in this type of game our knight would
probably come to e7 and will kingside
castle
and i think
no that was not played in the game
in the game uh my opponent had a
different idea which was somewhat
creative but did have a bit of an issue
he played queen takes
d4 now
um
and there's no tricky ideas here the
bishop can't check because the queen's
no longer on d1 and this knight can't do
any fun discoveries either because the
queen covers both of those squares
so he does just safely win this pawn and
defend his pawn
but there is a bit of an issue
with this move
how did i continue in the game
so a white to move in this position
uh yeah brent again nice in the chat
knight to f3
uh what's the idea of knight to f3
besides simply attacking the queen
there's a little something more to it
why is knight to f3 such a good move
here
while you're thinking about why knight
to f3 is the best move uh bishop e3 is
suggested in the chat what's the problem
with bishop e3
yeah it's the same problem right we love
these pawns apparently this one is
hanging so you got to keep your bishop
on uh there for now um but yes knight to
f3 brent it covers e4 as well
so actually the queen has no safe spaces
uh to keep defending this pawn right all
of these squares are attacked
so we have to retreat uh in the game
queen to d8 is played um whoops
there we go queen to d8 um
there are some interesting counter ideas
however
uh one possibility here
is f5 counter-attacking
uh keeping this pawn defended and
attacking the queen
although it gets a little weird here
after something like queen to h5 check
g6
and
it's it gets a little weird i think um
white is probably a little better
because our pawn structure is messed up
um
another move to consider here right is
uh forcing moves
check bishop to b for check and this is
kind of a tricky move with the idea that
normally c3 would be
the obvious response you know attacking
the queen and the bishop and forking but
what's the problem with c3 here
yeah
oh wait sorry the one on
the knight on e4 yeah
uh what's wrong with this knight
if
if you take it
the whole idea if you take the pawn
and then
yeah
gotcha um yeah so
the problem is
uh
so
there may be some idea you're looking at
if we take with the bishop and the
knight takes the knights actually pinned
to the queen so we would win the queen
however if the pawn takes it doesn't
quite work so better here is actually
that this pawn was just defending this
bishop
if it's pushed we can take it and again
we have some counter play it'll be a
little interesting
however king to f1 is actually going to
solve the problems but
let's get back to what's actually
happening in the game
queen to d8
and queen takes g7 attacking the rook
and here bishop to f6
really strong move defending the rook
attacking the queen
trying to hold everything together with
the idea that uh after knight takes
queen takes
and everything is defended
so black has lost this pawn but they're
trying to hold everything together and
they're doing it fairly well
in this position this i think will be
maybe the last of one or two tactics
before we wrap up today
but white to move and play a really
really pretty move
so yeah uh
ninchem i think is your name bishop to
h6
really really nice with the very simple
idea
of defen uh defending the queen and if
queen takes then bishop takes and the
rook is still trapped
so how did my
opponents
respond here
with
knight to d7
defending their queen and also defending
this very sneaky threat on f8
[Music]
right queen takes g7 doesn't work
because again the rook is lost
and if queen takes h6
then not
then the rook is lost again
but worse knight takes h6
seeming like
everything is defended the queen is lost
and there's also still this threat if
nothing else is done then queen comes to
fa and it's checkmate very
soon so knight to d7 defending all these
threats
uh bishop to b5 now played pinning the
knight
and unfortunately here my opponent made
uh
a slip up here he played knight takes h6
now
which did allow me to take
the queen because the knight is pinned
perhaps better in this position
would be maybe queen takes h6
and after queen takes rook um black is
worse right you've lost this rook but at
least you have the bishop and maybe you
can try and survive
uh maybe something like either here
queen coming to f8 or king to f8
defending the knight
and maybe there's even some strange
worlds where we trap this queen if
white's not careful
um
if queen takes g7 in this position then
still bishop g7 and white still wins the
rook
for nothing right we're not getting this
bishop here so it is probably best to
take on h6
but again uh just to quickly wrap up
right we're not going to go through this
whole game again but i want to emphasize
a big benefit is a lot of people
i think beginners especially don't
really analyze their games
if they do maybe they just do it with
like stock fish they just have the
computer on and telling them the best
moves
i don't think that's a good way to do it
i would say a good way to analyze your
games is kind of what we've been doing
today is to just walk through the game
slowly think about what each side is
planning
see if you've missed any moves or if you
lose i try to you know focus on the
perspective of the losing side because i
think we can learn a lot from games
where we lose is you can try and figure
out what was the moment that i started
to go wrong what did my opponent find
and take advantage of or what did i miss
uh did i have any opportunities to
improve my play
and i think doing that is really an
excellent step to
improving
your chess skill regardless of your
level but i think especially for
beginner players
so that is all i have for you today but
thank you for joining for beginner
breakdown and i hope to see you again
next week
take care